well time now for our daily debate and
today we're talking about something that
many of us hadn't really heard of a year
ago but it's certainly in the news now
we're going to start with the
contribution from the England rugby star
James Haskell you may have seen there
are quite a lot of fake news stories
operating on Facebook and I think it's
just Facebook may be out there on
Twitter the a I've died which is not
true
B I died of a steroid overdose not true
B I died of a drug overdose not true
that my career is over because I've an
ollie secret that I've been trying to
sell some drugs which when you click on
it tries to sell you drugs which is
bizarre and also something about I've
had to quit rugby and have left
everything my family and I've moved away
so just to make sure it's very clear
this is absolute rubbish
well that was James Haskell posting a
video to the nine reports circulating on
social media and now that was one of
many fake news stories posted on the
Internet
additional phenomenon that helped make
post truth than one of the words of 2016
so today we're debating what is fake
news and what if anything can we do
about it with me
our technology correspondent Tom
Cheshire Jim waters and a BuzzFeed and
Claire Fox of the Institute of ideas
right in your view what is fake news
give us an exam and yeah I think the
examples of the best ways going this one
we've got now is really going down the
black hole of fake news that starts
eating itself but this is a story about
Rudy Giuliani being bad his having a
council spended from Twitter because
here we go this is the fake news story
itself what he'd done apparently Rudy
Giuliani is tweeted a statement about
pizza gate which is Excel itself it's
the exemplar of fake news so pizza gate
was this idea it came from the hacked
emails which were put on WikiLeaks from
the DNC members some people started to
think that they were coded messages
they're referring to human trafficking
and a sex ring based at Comet ping-pong
which is a pizza restaurant in
Washington this went all around the
internet on Facebook on Twitter
actually it started on Twitter with the
white supremacist tweeting this and then
it just snowball end up with a man going
to comet ping-pong and with a rifle to
shoot yeah he shot the restaurant a bit
he saw three shots didn't actually shoot
anyone but he was arrested he said he
want to go investigate himself and he's
still not convinced that it isn't fake
news and then this comes back with this
Rudy Giuliani he tweeted this thing
saying Peter gate is true then his
account was suspended of course he
tweeted no such thing does actually have
a twitter account this is someone
pretending to be him but it gets picked
up all around the internet and before
you know it's there on Google search
results it's everywhere you look and it
just happens by itself it's amazing the
momentum it builds up and that's sort of
exemplary of the phenomena we've seen
all around the internet this year and
how all these systems play into each
other Twitter and Facebook and Google
this we using this is a Facebook problem
not just but is for everyone really and
it's rather worrying jbz people just
having a laugh in someone it's about
nothing it's genuinely quite a major
threat to how we sort of function and
sort of how we have a sort of agenda
that actually we can discuss things
within some reasonable bounds we have
got almost no control and distribution
now which for many reasons that's good
you no longer have to rely on the
handful of newspapers to get an idea of
what's going on in the world on the
other hand it means your mate John down
the pub who previously used to bang on
about strange things about Secrets going
on that he can get out there can now
reach a far bigger audience than any
newspaper can and you can do it with one
completely wild unsubstantiated
unverified story which gets straight out
there suddenly has 20,000 shares on
Facebook and millions of people who
don't know any better think that it's
there for a reason and how sometimes as
I understand it people can actually make
money from generating clickbait or so
right this is the really classic one
journalists have always unashamedly try
to push stories as far as they go we all
love a juicy headline we all have a
great bit gossip and then we often push
it just that little bit further to try
and make people take an interest in it
and that was how you sold papers that's
how you get people to watch TV shows
that's how you get people to tune in and
that was you know accepted the problem
this time is that no one are considered
a world in which you have no one
controlling the distribution other than
one company particularly Facebook based
in California to the point where if you
just make a completely fake headline
like that rugby player who says
you know people are clicking on stories
to see I've died obviously you click on
that if you're interested in that as a
player and then they're finding you
hasn't but you've clicked on the site
you've given some ad revenue to the site
that you've clicked on and you're less
interested in the much more mundane
day-to-day news which traditional
outlets are offering
I mean Claire Fox is is heading towards
entropy we're post truth lies and facts
are interchangeable
I think I'm interested in the political
discussion around it because if we get
the context you know a lot of people
have argued in a kind of very earnest
way that it's fake news stories that led
to Hillary Clinton losing the election
that fake news and Post trees is an
explanation for the brexit vote that's
when I get nervous because that seems to
me to be kind of paternalism too far
this idea that everyone was duped by
these stories that everybody's that kind
of idiot who kind of just sees this sort
of mad thing and then votes and so it's
been used in a sort of way to demonize
people you don't agree with because you
say those people only voted that way
because they were influenced by fake
news story but you see I mean let's talk
about Don Trump because he's someone who
has put out a lot of statements which
he's backed away from what happened
total victory now this is a new one from
him today this is about the whole
question of the popular vote the fact
that he Hillary Clinton got across the
country nearly three million more votes
than he did and he just says I would
have done even better in the election if
that is possible if the winner was based
on the popular vote I would have
campaigned differently but would
campaign differently so in other words
he's basically saying to his supporters
when people say Hillary Clinton got more
votes he they'll come back and they'll
say well basically that's because John
Donald Trump says he didn't try yeah but
I the thing that's galling about this is
not that I want to define defend Donald
Trump but he actually won the election
in the way that we would have accepted
that she'd have won it even if she'd
lost the popular she's not no I know but
I'm saying the debate around it ends up
falling into this mad situation so what
my concern is that serious journalists
are over playing the fake news stories
and the post truth phenomena to say that
this is the threat to democracy and
truth
I actually think we've got much bigger
problem by the way which is the threat
to democracy is the
anti-democratic in loving their behind
this discussion the problem is there's
always a counter argument which is that
it probably was a system that needed
reforming it's probably in fact it
definitely is much healthier that new
outlets such as mine BuzzFeed can come
along and break in entirely thanks to
the internet opening up
the news agenda the downside is that the
problem is through that gap are now
charging in we sort of breached the
walls and into the gap absolutely
everyone is charging it at time on
Twitter we've got the blue tick which
says you know it is theoretically it
says it really is you who's who's doing
this technologically other anyways of
sort of sorting stories and saying well
this is credible this is incredible it
is really hard in this Jim was saying
what the problem is that this stuff just
flies around and even people click on it
and the damage is already done you send
out a rebuttal I think what's
interesting is the big tech companies
you know they're kind of founded on
optimism whether it's Twitter everyone
thought that this would be a lovely
place for people to talk and instead
it'll turns into a den of trolls and
horrible abuse Facebook the same sort of
thing that we want to connect people but
both rely on advertising that relies on
people really engaging on it and they
don't really mind what you click on but
I think their site fit so Mark
Zuckerberg the chief executive of
Facebook had a lovely fireside chat with
Sheryl Sandberg talking about the year
in 2016 which was a fairly disastrous
one for Facebook and every other metric
than money but he said Facebook is a new
kind of platform it's not a traditional
technology company it's not a
traditional media company you know we
build technology and we feel responsible
for how it's used that's a bit different
from how it used to be they used to say
we're just pipes we just put it out
there now they're going to start
thinking a bit more about what they can
do about this but isn't there a
nervousness here I mean one of the
problems is that there's a lot of calls
for regulation we're seeing Facebook and
Twitter under pressure but sadly have
gone along with it to start censoring
things that they don't like and so we
actually end up for those of us who
believe in press freedom and actually
the pursuit of truth requires freedom I
mean in general just look at one of my
regular trolls here hey okay out of
bulton here's examples of fake news the
Syrian wave banner the good work of the
wife white helmets both Sky News stories
and
you know that's very insulting to Sky
News but it's out there it's on my
timeline and it's sort of saying all Sky
News is hard work is the equivalent of
one bloke accusers of fake news yep and
that's that's I mean that's basically it
you've ended up at the point and on that
the really scary bit is if you want to
complain about skyline eases coverage
there's regulators who do it if you want
to complain about something that's going
incredibly viral on Facebook wrongly or
rightly you're basically dealing with
the internal rules so I one company and
that's that's that is very very
fascinating so we're going to see a lot
of MPs in the next year making a lot of
efforts to change that in the house now
one of the things that I've been doing
talking to a lot of whether we call them
professional Germans at the end of the
year and you know Financial Times New
York Times The Times of London all say
well one thing that's happened is our
subscriptions have gone up people want
to go to trusted sources so is this
going to finish off is fate news going
to finish off real news or not no
absolutely not and but it is up to
mainstream journalists to up their game
you know it is also the case that
complacency doesn't work great
journalism was somewhat lacking of late
talk about echo chambers like the trolls
didn't create them the trolls didn't
make every newspaper around them but
that will miss the brexit story in
advance because they were talking to
themselves too much so I think that what
we need is good investigative journalism
that can just ride high above it and
they're not by the way gets so defensive
that it starts blaming fake news or
turning the fake news story into a moral
panic all right same fast-food is new
journalist a certain extent but
presumably wants to be trusted as well
yeah and we're putting lots of money
into investing and things like that and
we think that Basin has actually never
been a better time to be a journalist of
a good journalism it's just there's a
much worse time for trying to influence
people and get the word out there I
think those are both right but also this
happens every day you remember when
everyone used to think Nigerian princes
were offering them a lot of money we
figure out how to work on the internet
and I think that's why we've realized
this year a lot more people are aware of
fake news and other things and will
behave a bit better hopefully
umino stories aren't true anyway thank
you all very much indeed
this is all-out politics coming up